back again today with me i'm so lucky my
beloved desk mate
ross matthews hi oh russ i love you so
much i love you too it's so good to see
you and we're both wearing sweaters
today
isn't this cute i got it on sale and i
was like oh my god not a bow blast this
is a big day
all right let's kick off the cake of the
day because
we want to give cake information on our
news and today's cake is a king cake
it comes from the 12th century france
or in france i guess i should say and
now we know it is the cake of new
orleans and mardi gras
there's a baby in each cake and whoever
gets it
is king for the day ross yeah i want the
baby
you know the one thing is i want them to
be very careful about that baby though
because i go through a cake like the
tasmanian devil
i know and so i i feel like it's a
choking hazard also
i feel like i'm cheating i'm now just
searching for the baby is there really a
baby in this case there's a baby
somewhere they assured me but i have no
idea where
i'm taking a bite okay ross first yeah
it's your turn
oh it's my turn yeah okay you eat i'll
talk okay dru oh i love this earlier you
mentioned the piece from the new yorker
comparing dating during the pandemic to
being in a jane austen novel
well i looked into it and you're
absolutely right okay the similarities
are chilling in both of them jane austen
and dating during
pandemic the main characters lead quiet
domestic lives which is so true we're
not leaving the house
check check uh in both you regularly
inquire about the health of each other's
family members
right check check check how you sisters
and cousins how they do
i always do that and last but not least
you and your prospective
person barely ever touch and i can speak
from experience because you know
i met somebody in january that's right
before the lockdown happened and then
our whole courtship
has been really through zoom and
facetime we would like i would order
ubereats for him and we don't have dates
cute right i love this see and i was
excited for you
to be on like this subject and talk
about it because you
found love during the pandemic i did it
was tough you know and now i'm here in
the city we're together
but i feel like it also made it very
romantic because it wasn't just you know
i think it's great because it will force
us to go back to things like
letter writing which i don't think
there's a more romantic form of
communication
if you're trying to get a job or a
boyfriend write a letter
and having patience with the entire
process of courtship
it's like in my humble opinion it's an
art we've lost we just swipe left and we
expect
too much too fast leaving no room for
the get to know each other part of it
all
reach and as ken jong so eloquently said
a
gesture the uber eats those little
things are so
important ross i recently made a gesture
yep i sent a little care package to
someone wait wait for real
for reals i did it tell me everything i
don't know i don't know what will happen
and i have to tell you i sent it without
any expectation i was just so proud
to brush off the icicles and even just
think about
something cute to do and that's part of
like a romance everybody wants like a
response
from their gesture and i think that's
the wrong intention
i was just happy to do something and
have the intrigue enough to do so
how did we bury the lead in drew's news
i'm sorry you yeah it's been like five
years for you dating you recently sent
it out like a package
i sent a little thing and uh you know
i'm gonna report back first to you
okay all right all right next story i
have a million more questions but i'll
wait for commercial okay go go
well and you know i'm going to tell you
everything okay okay but this is really
funny because
lifetime the network lifetime we got a
steamy mini movie coming up this sunday
and you don't want to miss it
i actually we had to google it
immediately and look at a trailer
because i was like i don't get this i
don't understand what it is i know but i
was so excited
entertainment weekly reports that mario
lopez stars as a
sexy colonel sanders of ksc
that one in a recipe for seduction take
a look this is crazy
i think i'm falling for the new chef
jessica is falling for harlan the cook
leave jessica alone and skip he has a
secret recipe that's going to change the
world
harlan claims to have some secret recipe
a secret recipe
spare me we all have our secrets
okay are they trying to kill me right
kfc and mario lopez in the same thing i
mean talk about finger looking good
i don't know right but i i have a i'll
have a wing and a thigh if you know what
i mean
i just think that remember when lifetime
did that kristen wig will ferrell movie
too
like they do these wild things and they
take it seriously and i just think
yay for unique bold like programming
so okay fun all right well that does it
for us
on uh cake week did you find the baby
wait it doesn't do it for us on cake
week what am i talking about
no i did not find the baby where's that
baby
god just did hold on
[Applause]
tidy what does it mean if i have the
baby what happens now like you're the
queen
you're the king oh and you're the queen
you